a lot of white games today
all right i'll just go into a qgd
[Music]
yeah so as i mentioned before in that
other game in these positions the knight
doesn't really belong on c6 so i'm
spending time with my queen to induce it
just play e3
do i want to take d5 i'm gonna leave
i'm gonna leave this pawn on e6 usually
black doesn't take on c3 directly
so now 95 is a threat let's get our
queen out of there
just get castle
yeah i watched queen's game but a while
back um
anything in particular about it you were
wondering
i remember the checkmate she uses to
beat
celtic in the state championship
it was really nice
e5 is a little annoying maybe a take on
d5
takes don't want this bishop
i just want to get ready for this
evaporate black is preparing
now i'm actually just gonna put this
rook here in advance
but it feels a bit strange but black's
main idea by far here is e5
and so this being ready for it is worth
this move
e5 take e4
takes i don't mind
so it goes for this e4 fork but i take
here
takes and i'm up a pawn at the end of
the day
yeah the light squares are a bit scary
but i can go here
they'll play f3 at some points just to
shut this bishop out
i don't want to i don't want to do this
trade right away
i want to play f3 so i want to gain
tempo on the screen with one of these
moves
why not take earlier on g5 i didn't take
on d5 earlier because then black fixes
their pawns
i like this pawn being here it kills a
couple of black pieces
so i waited to take on d5 until black
had already played e5
and same thing if black takes on c4 then
i'm happy
but hang on so rook takes e5 is a threat
that's important to note
so let's see let's play
let's play c4
and same thing papa if black takes on c4
in those positions i take on c4 with the
bishop
and i'm happy because flax pawn is kept
on e6
all right so let's see this is another
temple that's hard to resist
just keep annoying black screen
and i mean i want to get this pawn
center moving forward
at some point maybe i'll take here
so my pawns can move forward and the
night's not in the way of my own bonds
chapter e4 bishop a4 this knight's a
little in the way
let's just get rid of it
and just move the bonds forward
yeah black's just kind of struggling for
air
that's the problem all right let's cover
f4
black wants to play f5 that's a little
annoying
so let's go here
f5 but now we can go e5
yeah just keep guarding the pawn
and this pawn center is just so strong
it's hard for black to find any play
right it's it's kicking the knight it's
blocking the rooks
now the bishop comes here and this
becomes an idea
but you'll kind of see in these sessions
i
i put a lot of effort into getting pawns
like this and you can kind of see why
they do so much for you they just take
away all the all of
the room from their pieces and they give
your pieces so many lines
so it enables things like this okay mml